Stanley Kubrick was the first director
that ever fired me
um full metal jacket and Vivian has
started took over but but it became this
weird strange thing so I was really I
mean it was maybe 18 19 and nice but as
soon as I was fired in other words
because I didn't know how to do what he
wanted me to do because Stanley Kubrick
knew everything he had studied drumming
with Gene kruber he just wanted me to be
his musical secretary and I'm not very
good at that I would get these capes and
drumming was ten fingers on his tabletop
I'd go well get a drummer to do exactly
that you know so that didn't work but
then once I was officially fired I would
get these phone calls or where he would
go I think Vivian's in a bit of trouble
can you go up there and see if she's all
right yeah or he'd go what do you think
of Dolby stereo I'm 18 years old you
know I have no idea I'm talking to
Stanley Kubrick